the latest target for russian forces
ukraine's biggest military base in the
west the international peacekeeping and
security center in yavarev is used to
train ukrainian forces it was hit by
several missiles
57 people are injured including
civilians nine people have died now the
fire is being put out
the kremlin appears to be widening its
net towards ukraine's western border the
base where joint nato military drills
are usually held is just 20 kilometers
from the polish border an entry point
for weapons aid from the west to support
ukraine
on saturday the u.s approved a further
200 million dollars worth of arms for
kiev prompting warnings from moscow the
corridors being used to transfer foreign
weapons into ukraine are legitimate
targets
nearly three weeks in and russia's
bombardment of ukraine is intensifying
by the day it's hard to keep track of
the amount of damage caused but the
kremlin on sunday said it's destroyed
more than 3 500 military facilities so
far these are the same corridors being
used by those fleeing the war
as russian troops advance closer to
ukraine's capital kiev daily evacuations
from the cities surrounding it have
doubled in the last 24 hours
this is maripol in the south east
relentless shelling has killed more than
1 500 people there so far
for nearly two weeks the port city has
been besieged no one can leave and no
aid can enter
thousands of people are still trapped
water is running out
russia's military has admitted the
situation in some ukrainian cities is
catastrophic but blames ukraine for this
the most difficult humanitarian
situation has developed in mariopol
hundreds of thousands of people
including foreigners are forcibly held
by nationalists who threatening physical
violence stop any attempts to leave the
city
on the ground the accounts of those
fleeing tell a different story two and a
half million people have fled to
neighbouring countries already and that
number keeps on rising every minute of
every day
we're shocked we're with children
rockets fell 20 meters from us we have
no food or water nothing we escaped
trying to save ourselves
another bombing campaign another city
flattened ukrainians continued to fight
the russians in volnovaca city in
donetsk in the east where russian forces
are increasingly taking more territory
we've been hiding here for days women
cook the meals and distribute them to
the needy we hope the nightmare will end
soon i had no idea it would be so
terrible but it's okay and we'll get
through it
while food and water supplies run low
across the country resilience remains
high
[Music]
in a war that appears to have no end in
sight
al jazeera
the u.n nuclear watchdog says it's
concerned about the safety and security
of ukraine's nuclear facilities the
zapariccia plant is under russian
control it's europe's largest with six
of ukraine's 15 reactors power lines to
the facility have been damaged in
a facility housing a research reactor is
being shelled repeatedly kamal and
ravine power plants in south ukraine are
still in government control and
operating normally the chernobyl nuclear
site hasn't had any active reactors for
more than 20 years but large amounts of
spent fuel and radioactive waste remains
on site its power lines were cut last
week diesel generators are providing
backup power
andrean procep is the director of energy
programs at the ukrainian institute for
the future now we're not disclosing his
location for safety reasons he doesn't
trust what the russians are saying about
the plant
the only source that i can trust uh
is ukrainian uh government and ukrainian
nuclear power company
who are saying that russians are trying
to establish control over their nuclear
power plant the same as they did with
chernobyl nuclear power plant which is
under the commission uh which is not
operating but still
it's
posing a high threat
for
for many countries in the case if
anything happens so in general uh
i might say that there were
more incidents because russia's were
shooting uh over the biggest in europe
nuclear power plant they were shooting
nuclear facilities and reactive
storages
in kiev in kharkiv so in general
situation is
it is very bad the truth is that ukraine
do have enough
qualified specialists to operate these
power plants without any uh
russian
this this assistance uh we we can do
this at high level and if russians
didn't invade ukraine
uh
so in the beginning
and they they're offering some technical
assistance that sounds crazy
ukrainians are moving as far away as
central america these were some of the
first to arrive in guatemala on friday
the government says they're being
admitted on humanitarian grounds
i don't know what awaits us in the
future but i hope the war ends soon it's
difficult to express the pain in my
heart for my father and mother who are
in the ukraine they can't leave because
they're 40 kilometers from russia
every day they see weapons and lots of
russian soldiers